hello thank you so much for having me so
CSS is really really powerful tool you
can use it for art now you can use it to
do pixel manipulation here is an example
of a code pen where I'm generating these
random polka dots with the help of sass
random function every time you refresh
you get a sort of different aesthetic
which is nice generative art you can do
things like this where you're just
playing with images applying different
filters and blend modes kind of like
lomography just seeing how creative you
can get it's a really nice outlet you
can even create infrared effects so
faking this infrared camera effect you
don't need special equipment or tools or
even going out into the field and taking
photos when you can use CSS to recreate
these effects and you can create 3d
images through the images where you're
applying different blend modes putting
them on top of each other is seeing how
they interact and creating these effects
sort of mimicking how the I can look at
an image now that there's in the browser
you can really interact with them you
can apply animation to them you can make
3d animated videos if you wanted in the
browser it's all possible and it's
really cool if you want to see any more
information about these demos I
mentioned you can check out art the web
com which has posts that sort of detail
more of how to do those things but then
I get this when I give this talk and
this woman is saying do you make money
from your art and the boy says yes and
she says really
so I want to show you how blend modes
are not just a little art piece that you
can show off they can be implemented in
your UIs and be a really nice way to add
a good touch to your projects and
websites so my name is Yuna and you can
find me on the internet at Yuna that's
pretty much everywhere github Twitter
I'm a UI engineer at digital ocean it's
a server company based in New York I
started a couple of sacks meetups that's
how I got involved in the scene started
to austins asked me that but I started
the one in Washington DC back in the
states and I also co-host a podcast
called tools day where it's about 20 to
30 minutes of tech tool talk a week on
Tuesdays roughly at two p.m. EST so
let's start with filters filters are
really great and super super powerful so
with filters we have blur brightness
contrast drop shadow grayscale you
rotate invert opacity sepia and saturate
and you can also combine any of these in
a space separated list in your CSS to
get multiple effects so a nice graphic
of all of them up here you can see that
they take different values a lot of them
are 0 to 1 inclusive like grayscale
brightness you can go higher than one as
well as contrast things like learning an
absolute value so an absolute pixel
value you can use ms don't use m's it'll
break your browser if you do anything
higher than like 10 pixels it's really
bad you can use an argument list and
drop shadow so familiar with argument
lists that's that's what that looks like
so just in one line of code you can
really transform your page the browser
support is pretty good and the other
thing is since they're just visual
effects a lot of the time there are nice
bonus so with progressive enhancement
you can just add them on top here's an
example of just using it really quickly
one line in a website so I i wrote this
it's just a image from my blog drew
these little sketches inside of an app
called paper and paper inherently has a
gray background but instead of opening
all of these images individually in
photoshop editing them putting them back
into my blog
I just added one line of code I don't
know if you could release it up there
but there was a difference between that
background color and a foreground color
I just use a lightning filter liteon 1.1
and bam if using something auto prefix
or you don't even have to prefix the
WebKit but if you're not these do have a
WebKit prefix to them another example of
thing that you can do is this a really
common pattern that we see for focusing
attention on an area so a sidebar here
this is the Dolce and Gabbana website
and what they do is when you click that
sidebar open a div pops up with this
semi-transparent black background that
lays over the page and it focuses your
attention on that side bar but we can
recreate this with blend modes we don't
need to have the additional diff we
don't even need to have a background
color there is a property hopefully
we'll get meted called backdrop filter
and backdrop filter is really cool
because not only can we create this
effect that sort of has that darker
color in the background we can't blurs
since it's a filter we can use any of
those 10 filters so remember he wrote
eight is one of the options we can do
you know we can change the brightness
value any of that and get that same
effect but it's so interactive and we
can do it just directly in the browser
we can prototype right here so if I want
at a brightness that means I can also
make it darker if that brightness value
is less than 1 so we don't even need
that line of code to the background
don't need a background at all in one
line of CSS is backdrop filter we can
recreate this entire effect it's pretty
cool this browser support is pretty bad
it won't want however there are
workarounds there are hacks that let you
do this here is another example of this
it allows that text to be much more
legible inside that modal window so it
has a light background but it's also
blurring that mountain image behind that
text so how do we recreate this in our
current modern browsers how can we do
this it's called the fixed background
hack and it looks like this what you're
essentially doing is applying the same
background to the page and the element
that you want to fake that blur effect
so I have here this fixed background and
I have zero cover so it takes up the
entire
so whatever i'm revealing of that
background as i scroll will reveal the
same spot as the background of the page
so since that's an element that we've
added on top of that background we can
apply filters we can apply blur we can
apply a brightness filter take that text
more legible and it creates sort of that
same effect that same idea you can add
draggable to it like that previous
example in code pen and there we go you
can do things like revealing images so I
can hover over this and get whatever's
behind it you can do this with text so
making text more legible on top of
images if you had links or information
about speakers or users and it's really
easy to do this just in a couple of
lines of code you can apply this filter
this is you know using on a prefixed
here so it's going to add that WebKit
prefix and then add some content
afterwards just in two divs have a
rapper and do within it and you have
created this effect which is a blur that
reveals some text as you hover on top so
another cool thing about filters is not
just is there a variety of options to
play with and choose from but you're
saving image requests with your hover
states with whatever active States focus
you want because you don't have to have
an image for your main view and a
separate image that you're downloading
onto your users site for that secondary
view you can just apply a filter to it
and that's saving you a lot of memory if
you're not sending multiple images of
the same thing to your users so filters
can be really really useful in that
sense and here's just a good example of
the variety that you can apply and
mixing some of them so filters are
really cool but really what I think is
awesome about the web today is blend
modes blend modes how divs and colors
can interact on the web and this is
really really powerful there's a lot
more variety than the filters so here we
have all these options and I come in a
couple of groups dark and multiply and
color burn will all make those images
darker there's the Lightman group which
is lightning screen and color dodge
there's overlay soft light and hard
light then there's two that are kind of
similar which is difference in exclusion
and last four are all color properties
so hue saturation color and luminosity
browser support is decent on these so
keep that in mind there are two
different ways to apply them there's
background blend mode which applies
these to an element that has multiple
backgrounds so if I have an element with
a couple of different photo backgrounds
or a photo background and a color on it
then I can apply a background blend mode
to it and it mixes it with in that
element itself if i use a mixed blend
mode which has very similar supports
very identical you're basically saying
that you want to mix that element with
the page around it so you guys an
example of using multiply on the right
we don't have it applied and on the left
over here we do have it applied it's
creating this really intense depth of
color because what it's doing is it's
taking each pixel value the luminosity
so that brightness value and it's
multiplying it it's like a transparency
if you shine a light through two
transparencies the dark values will
remain was light values will shine right
through and any intermediate values will
mix and that's exactly what's happening
here so you can really see the depth of
these gradients that are occurring in
the CSS background multiplied can be
used throughout your site to really
unify it and bring in overall aesthetic
to it I like giving this example of this
bright yellow it makes the white text
somewhat let people on the stage who
would have known I'm using yellow and
white could work and it's a theme that
continues throughout the site without
detracting from it they're using black
and white images and this pop of color
by multiplying it um what's really cool
about CSS specifically is since it is in
the browser it is live you can interact
with it so your users can get the sense
of delight as they scroll through and
the page is changing and you can do this
in just a couple of lines of code it's
in effect that I think is pretty cool
and unique to the web today CSS comp did
a really good job of this so on their
website this is the CSS conf that's
happening in Boston this year they have
these SVG blobs these gradient SVG blobs
that sort of move with the page as you
scroll and also a wiggle around the page
so you can see that they're slowly
changing shape on this page
and they're not really interfering with
the content they're adding to it they're
bringing a little bit of color to that
later down the page there overlapping
images you can also apply any of these
effects to images videos I mean so you
can apply them on things that are moving
interactive and I'll give an example of
that in a moment so with this we can
also create designs like this and make
them possible in the browser and when
you make a design like this which I
found on dribbble possible in the
browser you can make that accessible to
screen readers you can make it
searchable with search engines like
Google and your content is being
repeated on the page this becomes
content not just a JPEG that you had to
save out or a PNG which is pretty cool
we need to stop getting our inspiration
for websites from other websites and
this is something that I understand
happens for a reason people are really
focused on flat design which is great
for performance but now there are so
many more options with the web and how
CSS and HTML and JavaScript are
transforming that we can do better we
could get inspiration from fashion or
architecture illustration there's more
out there than just other websites to
take a look at I would love to see this
trend of people experimenting war online
another example that i found on dribbble
that's a similar aesthetic is this one
so again you can recreate this in svgs
and text instead of having to create a
separate PNG or JPEG that you're serving
to your users here's an example of the
next blend node I want to talk about
which is the screen blend mode and
screen is the total opposite of x I like
this example because it shows both so if
and multiply we are multiplying the
luminosity values of the pixels in
stream we are taking the inverse and
multiplying the inverse the way that you
get the inverse of a pixel value as you
subtract it from one so instead of eight
times VA being active layer B being the
background layer we are taking the
inverse of the active layers luminosity
value multiplying that by the inverse of
the background layers luminosity value
and then inverting all of that because
we're attracting both that from one and
that's how you're getting this affect
your you're basically lightening up all
the parts that you would be darkening in
multiply an example i want to show you
how to really use this and make it
interactive in your sights it's with
this portrait so here's a portrait of a
woman and say I wanted to apply an
interactive texture to it right so here
I have a video file because this is code
I can just go here and hit screen and
you have this instant video effects
created on your site again because this
is code I could just add some filters I
could add a blur filter and make this
dynamic you can have this be interactive
with your users and to show that this is
just what it looks like so something
that is super super flexible they can
play with on the web also I wanted to
see what this looks like in a gif format
so i recreated this exact same thing in
a gift as you can see it's kind of janky
he leaves a lot of the colors there and
also the file format size is incredibly
large so let's compare them we have the
blend mode over here I know 3.6
megabytes sounds large it's a huge image
that I use for this presentation and an
MOV file that's pretty long definitely
can use better video formats and smaller
images but just in this is an example so
even though that's really big when I
convert it to a gift it was 24.7
megabytes nobody wants to serve that
nobody wants to pull that from the web
so there are a few ways that you can use
this to your benefit and make it much
more performant on your site this is a
really clever example of screens I
wanted to share that I found online by
Yann Drewniak so he's creating this menu
where if you hover over you can see what
those icons are individually but
together it's just this really cute
little circle that sits on your page you
can also create text masks with mix
blend mode you can use the lighten and
darken blend modes or multiply in screen
I wouldn't recommend this because
background sorry text clip is a little
bit more well supported and performance
than this but it is an option it's
something that people can play with and
see online I really like this example
this is a sort of profile view Emma
Watson and she has this sort of gray to
blue gradient applied on top of her if
you could see that
and this is lightened and you can tell
that's lightened because in the dark
areas we lose a lot of the detail and it
kind of just makes it a little bit more
murky I really like this effect I think
it's a very unifying effect so the way
that works is if we want to take this
color like this pink color and lighten
it by this blue shade we get this nice
purple and it just does it first in the
browser so you can look at it pretty
simply if you remember that black is RGB
0 0 0 and white is 255 255 255 right so
when we're lightening it we're looking
at each of these RGB values and
comparing them which ones lighter 190 or
40 it's one I need what about the green
valley which one flight 2501 6160
exactly and then 240 and if you see
what's happening here that's how we get
this purple value at the end it's pretty
cool so it's dark and you're doing the
opposite where you're looking for that
smaller value closer to dark colors like
black and that's doing the same thing
comparing those values the next thing I
want to talk about is sort of on the
topic of this effect because it is my
favorite one so using lighten you can
create this sort of faded out vintage
the effect that can really unify page
and we're seeing this more commonly in
design and on the web so it looks like
this losing some of those detail in the
shadow and applying serve a wash over
this image the way you do it here i'm
using the background blend mode property
and two background images on that that
page so i have a color applied and that
background which is just the image link
basically i want to mix background of
lighten or the background blend mode of
lighten and then choose the darkest
color i want on that page so if i want
the darkest color to be that bright
yellow you can throw it all the way up
there to wash everything out that's
darker than it if I want to be like a
nice navy grey or a purple that this is
perfect for that so here's an example of
that so do a tone effect you can see
again in those shadows that you're
losing some of that color the shopify ad
campaign that came out for their year
interview
you sort of end of year you're in music
I thought was really cool like beautiful
colors really cool blend modes applied
and just mash together in a really nice
way okay so the next time I want to talk
about is the color blend mode and color
is really cool I mean here I'm going to
use this dog to show you I'm going to
overlap and then apply color so
basically what color is doing is it is
taking the hue value and the saturation
value of the active layer so the rainbow
colors and applying that to the
luminosity the dark and light values of
that dog behind it so that dog could be
black and white and have that color
applied to it and you would never know
it wouldn't make a difference whatever
color on tap you want to apply it's
taking those two values if you look at
this sort of ring of color you have
luminosity which again is your dark to
light value you have your hue so that
shade on the color wheel and then you
have how far away that color is from
fifty percent gray which is the
saturation and these are all their own
individual blend modes so you can apply
just luminosity of a color or an image
or a gradient to an image behind it it
will just take lightning light and dark
values you can apply just a saturation
of it or you can apply just the hue
value of it which allows for a lot of
different combination on the web here's
an example of that color applied to an
image behind it don't know if this image
is colored don't know if it's black and
white probably a smaller file size to
send if you're sending a black and white
image and it's just apply on this page
gives it a wash of color makes that text
a little bit more legible as well and
just gives it a nice overall effect I
spoke at a conference last month where
they use this icon system where they use
the stately a similar color of pink for
all the icons it was a nice way they're
sort of blend and bring the page
together for the intro video here they
did the same thing it's a nice unifying
effect because everyone's photos are
going to have different shades in them
and I was scrolling along the speaker
page and looking at all the speakers
thinking about okay so what are the tux
is going to be I noticed that one of the
speakers didn't have the color applied
it was just sort of missing I thought
well if we had you know CSS this
really easy cascading change to make
just in case this ever happens you don't
even have to open any of those images in
Photoshop and edit them manually you can
apply a single class to them and have
them all get that effect throughout the
entire page so we can do here is use
color I'll use that color blend mode
create this pseudo element this after
soo development to sit on top of the
image and because we're doing this in
the browser we can even open up devtools
and see what's color we like the best
this is like prototyping in the browser
instantly as fast as you can do it
wherever you are presenting your site to
your users so then you have this uniform
effect throughout your site but you know
you got to be wary of browser
differences maybe not all browsers
support this sort of thing and if you
think about it what we just did was we
applied a block of color on top of this
image of a person so if the browser
doesn't support blend modes you're just
going to see a block of color we can
mitigate this thing to embrace the
Cascade we can mitigate this by using
one of those hue saturation luminosity
values we can create the same pseudo
element this after pseudo element put it
behind the image apply a luminosity
blend mode of the image on top of the
color and so that is going to apply the
lightness and darkness values of the
image to the color behind it so if the
browser doesn't support blend modes
you'll still see the original image so
that's sort of how you take the inverse
of color and you are applying it in this
manner you can still edit this with
color throughout with your dev tools and
see what shades you like what you get
interact with it it all works the same
way so if you have an idea in mind here
the streak rating Instagram filters you
can really create anything and the way
that you can recreate any sort of filter
effect is through gradients because
gradients allow you to create multiple
blocks of color on a single plane and
that means you don't have to have
multiple divs to create these elements I
really like this idea of recreating i
just used instagram as an example but
figuring out how those gradients can
interact and work so here i have a
radial gradient some of the filters
didn't even need a blend mode
so here I have just a color a solid
color with a few different filters
applied so you can go through and really
use that as a baseline to compare and
create so create this open-source
project called CSS Graham which has a
variety of these filters applied and
they do have animatable properties
somewhat to them and it's totally
available open source if you want to
contribute if you want to grab this
available via CDN and apply it to your
images I've seen it in videos I've seen
it there's a coffee shop that has like a
little Minneapolis anything is this
which is pretty cool um but just
experiment and explore CSS Graham is not
the only thing out there there is now
vscocam which is CSS Co the CSS version
of it it uses the visco camp images and
recreates those and there's this one
that I think is pretty cool and unique
color filter which is same idea but
they're kind of returning that bright
Spotify effect and the URL is sort of
long so if you want to go back to this
one I would take a picture of it but
lucky video duck it helped that I 0 /
color filter you could write that
dentally fast so next I'm I want to talk
about is a mix of a few blend modes and
that is the overlay blend mode so here
you can see that applied to the text of
that calculator and overlay is
interesting because it takes to the
screen blend mode and the multiply blend
mode applies the screen blend mode to
the light values at fifty percent and
the dark values get the x 1 mode applied
and it really makes us like nice sort of
not dramatic effect looks like this
closer up the calculator as it's darker
on top the numbers on our darker and
lighter ones are lighter so it creates
like a little smooth effect a little bit
better seen here in this border so in
the light values it's it's lightning
that image by the same percentage as it
is in the dark values so instead of just
like a white border around it it makes a
more unified visualization all right so
the difference blood mode the best way I
like to explain this is with these
little games do you remember these games
from childhood can you spot the
differences between a number one number
two well the CSS we can just keep
so what difference does is it looks at
all the pixel values it looks at the
difference between all the colors RGB
and a from the active layer and
background layer and takes absolute
value so with difference similar pixels
will turn black with exclusion they'll
turn that fifty percent gray and this is
really used for lining up transparencies
in the past making sure they were
perfectly aligned and I'll show you why
I hover over this you can see oh we're
cheating those are all the answers all
the differences so Sarah drives are
capable this idea of visual regression
testing with the difference blend mode
because you can just look at your before
look here after apply one line of code
and see what the differences are pretty
cool took that idea and sort of expanded
on it and created this site called
Tiffany which allows you to do visual
regression testing in your browser with
CSS just one line of CSS code works
locally because just behind your
firewall if you want to compare a
staging site to anything you have local
or an active site and see what visual
regression you've introduced into that
site CSS pretty cool so in review CSS is
awesome we all do that when it works
that's the caveat so don't do these
things because you know browser supports
not fully there yet if you really need
to support older browsers not highly
recommend this if you do need to support
other browsers and you want to try the
blend modes consider the ordering of
your divs and your images because it's
still really possible to apply this and
progressively enhance your website to
use these effects performance it is
still faster to use a pre edited image
that you're sending to your page rather
than edit them on the page itself
because you have to paint that image and
then apply the filter so you have to
repaint it repaint the pixels on top of
that your browser is doing calculation
so there's a little bit of a performance
hit to this you also can't save the
images which could be a good thing
depending on if you want your users to
grab your images but if somebody right
clicks and save
it they're going to get the unfiltered
unedited version of that rather than the
nice filter that you applied on the page
unless they take a screenshot of course
and there's no thumbnail support so what
I mean by this is if you hear it on
Twitter or Facebook people can see your
content but they're not going to see the
filter that you applied to it because
it's not native to the page so consider
that as well but do try this because
performance I know I just said this and
they don't try this category but um we
did show how it is good for performance
in terms of that video if you wanted to
make something really dynamic there are
certain cases where this is a lot better
in performance that one was a big one
also you don't have to send multiple
image requests so that could be a place
where if you look at sort of what you
gain and what you lose from doing these
filters you probably will gain a lot
more if you're sending two images to
your user for your hover effects or
focus effects flexibility hovering
interacting this provides for a lot of
interaction on the web natively you
don't have to use JavaScript for this
it's really cool I'm consistency so
embracing that cascade allowing for all
those styles to be generated from one
bit of code keeping your code really dry
speed of prototyping because we can do
this directly in our browser we don't
have to worry about doing in Photoshop
sang into the developer having them
apply it you can just work with
designers sitting next to each other
doing pair design pair programming and
sort of figure out what you want on the
spot which is great for those
last-minute changes to always happen
always happen but it's nice you can see
it directly in the medium which you're
presenting accessibility for those
artistic designs not just accessibility
with text and screen readers but
allowing that to be searchable by web
search engines making your site a lot
more semantic and exploration this is a
big thing the ability to sort of explore
with coming up in CSS and seeing what we
can do to push that further because the
only way to push the web forward is to
build something that pushes the web and
using things that push the web is how we
can do that so this is sort of like an
awesome website it's called evolution of
the web and here we can see sorta
we're technologies have come in and go
and right there is CSS animation and
it's kind of hard to see it's pretty new
flexbox is also really really new in
comparison to all this the filters are
like baby they're like toddler stage you
know but they're brand new so browsers
are still really really working on
implementing these making them really
perform it in the browser and so now is
the time to sort of explore and see what
we can do with them and help the
browsers open bugs there's a big queue
they can really participate with like
Mozilla tweet at browsers they often
will like reply and say okay we're
working on this or tree off it that way
there was like a little trend lately
that was like hashtag edge bugs they
could tweet at them pretty pretty cool
so be an explorer and art the web try
these things out thank you
[Applause]